SHANNON LOW: Welcome
to Playtime 2018.
[APPLAUSE]
It's amazing to see
all of you here today
in this incredible space.
I look out, and I
see familiar faces,
people I'm going to
meet, new friends today.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's 10 years of Android.
5 years of Playtime EMEA.
I'm thinking, look how
we've all grown up.
Thank you for joining us
from over 40 countries
across Europe, Middle
East, and Africa.
My name is Shannon Low.
I head up the apps and games
business development team
for Google Play in EMEA.
We wanted to kick
off today with this
I Make Apps film because
this campaign and Playtime
both share the same spirit.
They're both about
celebrating you,
the people behind
apps and games,
the Android and Play community.
We all know that it's
the community that
powers any platform.
Without you, we wouldn't
be where we are today.
2018 is an incredibly
important milestone for us
because, as I said before,
Android debuted 10 years ago
on a single device.
Everyone remember
Android Market?
We had 50 apps in total.
And of course, those
important barcode scanners
and ringtone editors
that everybody needed.
I'm sure there are some
folks in this room here
who were working on barcode
scanners and ringtone editors
10 years ago.
Those were humble
beginnings for all of us.
But it set us on a good path.
A path for Android to become
the most powerful and important
popular computing platform
on Earth, with devices
available in every shape,
size, and price point
around the world.
As connectivity has become
near the ubiquitous,
we use our devices
everywhere for things
that we couldn't have
imagined 10 years ago.
And that's all thanks to you.
You have changed how we
interact with each other,
how we get things done, and
how we even spend our time.
You created new experiences,
new industries, new economies
thriving in communities
all over the world.
Simulating employment.
Inspiring entrepreneurship.
Our team is especially
proud of the work
that you do here in EMEA.
And it's great to see
that it's all paying off.
Since the beginning of the
year, the number of you
based in our region
who are making
$1 million dollars or more
per month on Google Play
has grown by 54%.
54%.
That's a huge leap.
And one business model that's
working well for many of you
is subscriptions.
Subscriptions revenue has
doubled in the past year,
and grown four times since 2016.
At Play, we view
ourselves as your partner
in helping you grow your
apps and games business.
We've made huge investments
in people, technology,
processes to help you
succeed on Android.
We're very proud
of what we've been
able to accomplish together.
But at the same time,
we realize that there's
much more to be done.
That's one of the reasons
we are here today--
to continue listening to your
feedback, to share experiences,
and to learn more
from each other.
To tell you more
about what we're
doing to continue helping you
grow your business on Android
and Play, please welcome
our keynote speaker,
Tian Lim, our Vice
President of UX and Product
from Google Play.
Tian.
TIAN LIM: Hi, everyone.
Good morning.
My name is Tian.
And I run Product and
UX for Google Play.
I'm super excited to share
a little of what we've
been doing to help
you reach more users
and build successful businesses.
I'm actually still
pretty new to Google.
In literally five days time
will be my one year anniversary
at Google.
And I joined because it's
just an incredible opportunity
to help so many people
around the world, both users
and developers.
One unique experience
I want to share
with you that I had this year
was my short time in Nigeria.
We went to Nigeria for the
Google for Nigeria event.
We were rolling
out Google Station.
Free Wi-Fi for everyone.
And I had the opportunity to
meet developers and influencers
there.
And I have to say, it was
just absolutely inspiring.
I met developers
that Google trained.
And once they became
certified Android developers,
they were making 10
times more than what
they used to make before.
Or they were building companies.
Local companies solving
real local issues.
The kinds of problems
that you can only
solve if you're
living in that market.
And here there's
a game developer
nestled between the
YouTube and movie stars.
And he has a small
game for kids teaching
them African languages.
And he found a global audience.
Basically, the African
diaspora trying to reconnect
with their cultural heritage.
These are some
inspirational stories
that I came away with
in my short time there.
Now, this is just one small trip
talking to a few developers.
But here at Google
Play, every month
we talk to thousands of you.
Listening to you helps us
focus on what's important.
I wanted to start the date by
focusing on the user and three
things that they care about--
quality, safety, and well-being.
Everybody here represents some
of the highest quality apps
and games in the Play Store.
You know that your
investments in quality
pay off with highly
engaged users.
The flip side, of course,
is a high crash rate
tends to lead to more
one star ratings.
On the Play Store, we want
to recognize your commitment
to quality.
And that's why our search
and discovery algorithms now
consider app quality
and user engagement.
This means that apps and games
with better retention, fewer
crashes, and fewer
uninstalls get
recommended more frequently.
To help you measure app
quality and improve it,
we have been investing
heavily in Android vitals.
And we have seen that developers
that engage with vitals
can dramatically improve
their crash rates, which
directly leads to better
ratings and better engagement.
Now, we've heard your feedback.
We've heard the feedback
that the data's great.
But it's not super actionable.
So today, we are linking
fully pre-launch reports
with Android vitals.
You'll hear a lot more about
this from Fergus and Gavin.
But I have to say,
this is amazing stuff.
What's going to happen is
when Vital sees crashes out
in the field that we've already
seen in the pre-launch report,
you can now connect these
two pieces of information
together and see videos and logs
of exactly the kinds of issues
that users are seeing
out in the wild.
And so this can directly
help you prioritize
which issues in the
pre-launch report
to focus on because
you know that users
are hitting these issues.
Let's talk user safety.
Another very interesting aspect
of my short time at Google
is seeing the many
new and creative ways
that our adversaries have come
up with to abuse our users
or exploit our ecosystem.
Well, let me tell you, we're
not having any more of this.
We're working super hard to
turn the tide on this problem.
And this is an area
that I actually
had to get personally
extremely deep on.
And I'm very proud
of the team and both
the automated and manual
ways in which we fight
this problem every single day.
It's really tough work.
But it's really good work.
Android and Google
Play have always
taken security and privacy
extremely seriously.
It's simply not negotiable.
Every app and game undergoes
an extensive security review
before they are published, using
a combination of both machine
learning automation and humans.
And as a result, 99% of
apps with abusive content
are identified before
people can ever
have a chance to install them.
Even after publishing,
Google Play Protect
scans every app installed
on the Android fleet.
That's 50 billion
apps every single day
that we're looking at
and checking for anything
out of the ordinary.
As a result of
all these efforts,
people who download
apps exclusively
from the Google Play
Store are nine times less
likely to install a
potentially harmful app.
So that's a little of
what we do for the safety
of the ecosystem.
But we need your help.
Our policies are constantly
changing and adapting,
working to keep the ecosystem
safe for you and your users.
Your input is critical.
And my team and I are
extremely grateful
for the active
dialogue that helps
us strike the right
balance between user safety
and your ability to innovate.
Our goal is to
ensure that users are
aware of how their
data is being used
and that that access
is reasonable.
So last week, we
announced a set of changes
around the SMS and
call log permissions.
This is to make
sure that developers
who request these
permissions only
do so when it is
absolutely necessary.
And we spoke with many of you
to understand your concerns.
And I can guarantee that our
final decisions were heavily
influenced by all
these conversations.
You can expect us to
continue to review
all the various permissions
and these types of changes
with the community
in the months ahead.
We will also be working
to ensure that we give you
sufficient notice to make these
changes and details on how
to implement them.
For example, on November 1-- and
a not so subtle reminder that
we will require all apps
and updates to target API
level 26 or higher.
This helps bring security
and battery life improvements
to all our users.
And these are the
kinds of benefits
that can only be realized in
the ecosystem when all of us
get on board.
We announced this 10 months
ago with explicit instructions
on how to comply.
We need you to be on top of
these and future changes.
So please make sure that
you have the right contact
information on the Play
Console, read our updates,
and engage with us as we
roll through these changes.
Now, we've talked
about high quality
apps in a safe environment.
But increasingly
people have been
thinking about striking the
right balance with technology
as well.
I, for one, escape my
technology by subjecting myself
to extreme endurance
sports and extreme amounts
of physical abuse.
This is literally what happens
when I'm not out here trying
to help users and developers.
I get shocked with 10,000
volts of electricity.
Now, our research
shows that while much
of the time that we spend on
phones is useful and valuable,
many of us still wish that we
could disconnect more easily.
That's why at IO this
year, we announced
our digital
well-being initiative.
We added capabilities
directly into Android P
to help expose and control
our digital habits.
We added a usage dashboard,
daily app limits,
the shush gesture,
and wind down,
and many other features
all to help people find
the balance that they need.
As businesses, we all
need to think critically
about the longevity
of our apps and games
and how we can sustainably
engage our users
without burning them out.
Yesterday, I was
very lucky to attend
a meetup for the Sustainable
Engagement Forum.
This is was extremely
robust conversation
with great cross-pollination
between different kinds of apps
and between game developers
and app developers.
It was really, really exciting
to see the community rally
around the cause for
sustainable engagement.
So to recap, we've talked
about important ways which
we are improving the user
experience through quality,
safety, and digital well-being.
But how do we connect
more of them to you?
So let's dive into some of
the new tools and features
that we've built after
listening to you.
In particular, the amazing
potential of our new
app distribution model.
Some new features to help
attract and engage new users.
And tools to help you
monetize your business.
App sizes.
They've grown dramatically.
Over the past four years,
they have tripled in size.
But as you know,
larger apps reduce
install conversion and
increase in uninstall rates.
And that's one reason we
built the Android App Bundle.
With our new format, we're
able to serve only exactly
the code and resources
that a user needs
for their specific device.
Since launching in IO in May,
several thousand app bundles
have been deployed
to production.
And on average, those apps are
seeing a 35% reduction in size
compared to universal APK.
We are really excited
about its potential.
And you'll hear a lot
more about the bundle
and the benefits of
smaller modular apps
in the next session.
So we just re-architected the
entire distribution pipeline
to deliver your apps
more efficiently.
But we've also
introduced new features
to help you attract
and engage new users.
Pre-registration lets you gather
interest for an upcoming launch
in order to help boost
your day one installs.
And since we launched
in early access,
we've generated
more than a quarter
billion pre-registrations.
We're excited that
the program is now
available to all our
app and games partners
and is fully self-serviced
in the Play Console.
You will also now
have the ability
to grant user rewards
to those early users.
And we've integrated
pre-registration with Google
Play Instant, letting your users
try a product before it even
launches.
You can see an
example of that here
on the left with Looney
Tunes World of Mayhem.
Google Play Instant also
supports premium applications.
As you can see here on
the right with Umiro.
We've also made these
instant experiences easier
to build with integrations
into Cocos Creator and a Unity
plugin that is now available.
And we've done all
this because we
know that Google Play
Instant can help you
with user acquisition.
We also have another
new launch that
will help with your conversion.
It's been one of
the top requests
from developers
around the world.
And that's to modify
store listing pages based
on user country, not language.
So now you can do this.
Quick example here.
Halloween in the US, coming up
next week, and Diwali in India.
They're each about a week apart.
But users in both countries
tend to have their devices set
to US English.
So targeting by
language is not helpful.
With country star
listing targeting,
you can now change the
store listing content
based on the user's country.
So here the icons and photos
are not only different,
but the descriptions can now
highlight different features
or talk about different events
in the different regions.
So now that we've covered
some of the new features
to help bring users
into your app,
let's talk about helping
you monetize your business.
Our commerce platform
makes it easy for people
to securely purchase on Play
in over 150 markets via credit
card, direct carrier billing,
PayPal, and gift cards
that are available in over
800,000 retail locations.
Subscriptions, as
mentioned, continue
to be a rapidly growing trend.
And we have a lot of
features in the pipeline.
But here's a taste of
just a few of them.
On left, in early access,
is subscribe and install
on details page.
So as you can see, this combines
the free trial, sign up,
and the install button.
And it captures user intent
to subscribe without having
to wait for the install.
In the middle, you'll
see the EAP for pause.
So a user may be
going on vacation.
And rather than let that
user cancel and churn out,
this gives them some control
to put their subscriptions
on pause and helps
keep them with you.
On the far right, you can
see plan change support.
With price changes
for existing SKUs.
With deferred upgrade
and downgrades.
Along with a strong
growth in subscriptions,
we're seeing more developers
adopt a hybrid approach
to monetization.
And one trend has been to
reward users for an action
like watching a video
ad with in-game currency
or other benefits.
So today, we're excited to
announce a new monetization
type called rewarded products.
The first offering being
a rewarded video format.
Users can elect to
watch a short video.
And upon completion,
are rewarded
by the developer with
either virtual goods
or in-game currency.
This new offering is powered
by Google Ads technology.
And it uses the same API calls
for in app purchases on Google
Play today.
No third party SDKs required.
We're currently in closed beta.
But we will share more details
with you in the coming weeks.
So I've covered a lot
in about 15 minutes.
And as you know, there is a
huge range of existing features.
It can be extremely
tricky for any of us
to keep it all in our heads.
So to help you take advantage
of all the tools and programs,
we're launching the
Academy for App Success.
Today, there are now 10
courses with information
ranging from managing your apps
release to granting refunds.
And going forward, we'll be
supporting more languages
and adding more
content to help you
take advantage of everything
that Play has to offer.
So we hope you check it out.
So now that we've talked about
some of the tools for growth
on mobile, I wanted to touch on
the broader Android landscape.
As you know, we continue to
push our apps to many devices
with Wear OS,
Android TV, and Auto.
And across even more
surfaces with Assistant.
Today, I'd like to focus
briefly on Chrome OS
and how this growing ecosystem
is an exciting opportunity
for developers.
So, Chromebooks
have gone from what
seems like a small
experiment to being
available throughout the world.
They range from traditional
laptops to convertibles.
And we've built all of
these in partnership
with some of the best OEMs.
Like Samsung, HP, and Dell.
They're available in over
10,000 stores worldwide.
And we continue to explore
and expand our footprint.
Last week, we announced
exciting an new device.
The Google Pixel Slate.
It's a great example of our
commitment to the Chrome OS
ecosystem.
It was designed to bring
games and apps to life
with a brilliant screen
and great performance.
So let's take a closer look
at a couple of great app
experiences optimized for
Chromebooks and Pixel Slate.
Gameloft wanted Asphalt
8 Airborne to give users
more precise control.
And because Chrome OS
treats its physical keyboard
just like an external
keyboard on an Android phone,
Asphalt 8 was able to support
keyboard controls using APIs
from Android Platform SDK 26.
The result was pretty amazing.
A whopping 6x increase
in daily access
for users on Chromebooks.
And a 9x boost in revenue.
The Gameloft team was so
excited by the strong results
that optimizing
for larger screens
is now standard
operating practice.
And they've just
finished optimizing
their latest addition in the
series, Asphalt 9 Legends.
Another app is Evernote.
The Evernote team was extremely
excited to use low latency
stylus APIs to quickly implement
touchscreen handwriting
and enhance layouts for
those wider screens.
Now, without the
latency, their users
can really feel like
they're drawing on paper.
The result?
Users of Evernote on
Pixelbook spent 4x more time
than on other devices.
So these developers went
beyond a mobile-only strategy.
And they adapted their
products to serve consumers
on a larger variety of devices.
And as a result, saw massive
increases in user engagement.
So perhaps you have
the same opportunities.
And because Android apps
are available on Chrome OS,
you can take your app, and
with very few adjustments,
optimize it for these larger
screens and form factors.
So it's really easy.
More surfaces.
A larger creative canvas for
you from the same binary.
I can't wait to see what amazing
stuff you all come up with.
So that's about it for me today.
Although I talked about user
needs and some new things
to help you connect
those users to you,
the bigger theme to all this
is that we are here for you.
You are all the
inspiration for our work.
So please use this
opportunity to talk to us
and give us feedback so that
next year we can bring forth
even more announcements and
features based on your ideas
and inspiration.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]